welcome to the thankful Thursday I
believe that you need to take time out
of your day today to thank somebody
who's had an impact on your business
because you can't do this alone you need
help people helped you get to where you
are right now and take five minutes just
to say thank you so today i want to
thank Basquiat picasso now basket
Picasso has a popular youtube channel
with motivational videos and he did one
video for me called believe by basket
Picasso that's done well has lots of
great comments and views on it and after
doing a few of the motivational videos
with a few YouTube artists I thought I
want to make this more of a regular
series I want to do a once a month video
on my channel because the messages are
so helpful I find for entrepreneurs
helpful for me keeps me going keeps me
energized and I thought it could help
other entrepreneurs as well and this is
this is a great learning lesson a
learning opportunity for you or and for
me I reached out to two people and the
first guy i wrote to and basically i
said i want to do a monthly series and
he wrote back to you know I don't know
if I have the time and and he's asking
ok what's the budget and asking a
million different questions and we
didn't seem that excited about it and
and for me that is always a red flag
warning sign right if somebody's coming
to work with you if their partner in
your business if it's a some kind of
outline to trying to set up if it's an
employee who's trying to get hired if
they're not passionate if they're not
excited if they're asking a million
questions and and you need to convince
them about why it's a good opportunity
dump it it's not going to work you need
the person who has the fire who gets
what you do who loves it and wants to
work with you so that first guy like you
know what it's ok cool I don't think
it's gonna be a fit for us no worries
and then I also wrote to basket Picasso
and he wrote back pretty quickly insane
Evan
i'm in i love your videos there's so
inspirational entrepreneurs I want to
help out I can get the first video done
this weekend it was like a thursday or
friday i wrote to him i can get it done
this weekend yeah man that's the passion
that's the excitement that's what I love
to see and so so we're working together
to launch our first one the first one is
up on the side already it's called if
today was your last day and and we're
gonna hopefully be doing a series of
these one that comes out every month to
help inspire and motivate millions of
entrepreneurs so basket Picasso I want
to say thank you thank you for your
energy thank you for your drive thank
you for your mission to go out and help
motivate and inspire millions of people
around the world I love it it's an honor
to be able to do this alliance with you
I'm feeling it and for all of you
watching take time five minutes a day to
say thank you to somebody who's helped
you in your business somehow there could
be a friend a family member a colleague
someone in the media you know somebody
who's helped mentor you someone who look
up to they have no idea who you are
doesn't matter just take a little bit of
time today to say thank you to somebody
it'll make you feel great it'll make
them feel great and will help continue
to let your business grow believe thank
you guys so much for watching you can
subscribe to the channel to see more
videos just like this I'll see you soon
don't forget to sign up for my free
newsletter its energy in your inbox
every single week hi i'm jason j reyez
fonseka of ra's online com and i want to
say Evan Carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun inspiring and XD only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period